let me pull this up right here
i have this poll from civics i love
showing
black lives matter
opposition support
general sentiment
people may start rioting this weekend
over amir lock being shot and killed by
police and you know what
i don't want people to get hurt i don't
want there to be riots i don't want
people to riot i don't want people to
get shot by cops but you know what
democrats establishment media
you if you do this you will face such a
reckoning man
take a look at this
before this is this is among all voters
is this all voters those independent
voters sorry
before george floyd died support for
black lives matter among independent
voters was at 41 and opposition was 28.
after george floyd died 51 percent of
independent voters
supported black lives matter then the
riots happened
and the support started to completely
crash then jacob blight got shot
after the derek chauvin trial
black lives matter support dropped
dramatically and opposition rose
dramatically
right before check this out right before
the ahmed arboring ahmed arbory verdict
opposition was going down and support
was going up and then right after the
verdict opposition went up
so these people want to come out and
they say oh armored armory and these
people he was jogging they lynched him
why do independent voters now oppose you
more
following that verdict
because people were lied to correct
that no that's the guy who was going to
go it's because people were lied to i
mean look and at the end of the day
no one yes is if you find something
that's wrong sure let's go ahead we're a
nation of laws
i think that the lawlessness that the
left basically promotes with these
quote-unquote protests which are actual
riots no one can get behind that and
that loses support and especially
whenever there's some type of a you know
a
jury that you know sees the case and
actually renders a verdict on it
they feel that justice has been rendered
and so the continuation of lawlessness
doesn't actually
increase the awareness to your cause it
actually denigrates it because it's just
lawlessness justifying lawlessness if
democrats want to preserve whatever
votes they might get they need to come
out right now and say do not protest do
not you mean like president trump when
he said
go home peacefully
but yet somehow that was inciting
violence dude trump was up against the
military-industrial complex he had a
challenge these guys are on the side of
that thing and they're trying to
manipulate the voters only trump is
trying to manipulate everybody and not
not in the
and people didn't like it because they
thought that how can a billionaire be
the
voice of the people but the reality was
that is exactly what he was trying to do
he was trying to build the middle class
he was trying to hold our adversaries
accountable he was trying to stop our
trade imbalances because i mean the guy
is the art of negotiation and he became
from the art of negotiation to the art
of peace deals i mean you look at
abram's accord look at all the different
things that he was doing so again this
this is he did more in four years than
most do in eight it's remarkable how
donald trump gets gets attacked for that
by the establishment left once again
they're like well these deals are
actually bad it's like you know what man
it is we we are we are truly living in a
period of
of psychosis
but let me just stress
i love civics because you can see that
independent voters this is brilliant by
the way the oh yeah they tend to reflect
republicans
so when we talk about
which side is truly right well
independent voters and republicans agree
with each other for the most part i
think it's fair to say at the very least
the majority of people disagree with the
establishment democrat world view and i
think it's fair to say based on
simple research like they lied about all
these things hands up don't shoot talk
about a lie you know that story ian
michael brown had his hands up
and that the uh darren wilson i think
was the name of the cop was that cup
shot and killed him and they started
marching out their hands up hands up
don't shoot and then the obama's report
comes out showing he didn't have his
hands up in fact actually
eric holder's justice department he
rushed the cop and he reached for his
gun he literally committed suicide are
we talking about the same eric holder
who's responsible for fast and furious
which is actually putting weapons to the
hands of cartels that are being utilized
against our cbp today so if the if the
democrat voter wants to believe those
lies and live in wally world by all
means go ahead and do so but if they
want to get violent and and start
fighting as they've been doing we got a
very serious problem it was not a
right-wing trump supporter who uh went
into uh portland and shot and killed a
bernie supporter was the other way
around that's right it was a black lives
matter supporter with a tattoo on his
neck who shot and killed the trump
supporters walking down the street well
i mean think about it look at the you
know antifa.com website where does it
actually take you to well during the
campaign when you would type in
it would actually take you over to one
location but my point is though we know
who the intolerant actually support and
they support democrats more than they
support the conservatives i mean we've
seen that time and time against the
liberal economic political no no to be
fair
antifa.com was likely bought purchased
by someone on the right i thought you
redirected it too was it joe biden
well it was it was done by joe it was it
was supporting biden harris and now it
actually auto links to the
whitehouse.gov corey when you're in the
military what was it like knowing that
we're part of this liberal economic
order and the military-industrial
complex is out there and like but it's
still important i understand like the
value of the us military we really can
make the world a better place we can
preserve a lot of goodness but what was
it like psychologically well i got to be
honest with you when you're serving in
the military i'm not thinking about the
industrial complex i'm not thinking
about gd lockheed martin and the other
you know we're going through these
military trainings and we're sitting
here looking at cohesiveness and we're
looking at our brothers to the left and
right of us you're not thinking about
any of these things you're only thinking
about keeping one another safe you're
only thinking about the fact that you
know again i tell people this all the
time it's not the boots it's the suits
you know whenever something goes wrong
and these boards are being volunteered
and you know voted on it's not us who
are sitting in the military who are
actually voting on these things we're
just out there to basically follow
orders and be able to try and go ahead
and do what we thought is the right
thing which to provide protection for
our constitutional liberties and
freedoms or to help free the oppressed
you know the old special forces the
oppressor libra mentality so as someone
who was in the military i wasn't
thinking about the industrial complex i
wasn't thinking about these generals
looking at their million dollar boards
after they get done retiring i was
thinking about making sure that my guys
who were in my team were going to be
safe on the ground that was it people
complain about just following orders but
it's like can you even have a military
if people don't just follow orders well
well look so here's the thing i'm
i'm one of those people that if you tell
me go out and kill these children and
you know we're just telling you to do it
so you should do it no i'm not going to
do that i mean it's not blindly
following orders it's looking at the
facts so
let's just say as an example regardless
of the reasoning for the iraq war you
know regardless of the falsified
documentation or the anthrax or the wmd
whatever the case may be we did know for
a fact that saddam ran in a tyrannical
rule we did know that there was shia
that were being just slaughtered you
know at random we did see the halabja
incident with the kurds we did see so
it's like you know you're still
eliminating a bad guy right the problem
with america is that not that we're you
know going in and eliminating terrorists
or bad guys the problem was that we
thought that we could actually create
democracy this nation building thing is
the biggest quagmire that the bush
administration ever put us into and it
was the biggest mistake and that was to
prop up the industrial complex let me
ask you about these uh the police we've
been seeing as of recent with what's
going on in the convoys the you know the
cops arrested that 78 year old men but
also the black lives matter protests
you've obviously got the left they've
been screaming abolish the police for
the past two years for really stupid
reasons but uh after a while i started
saying the same thing because not only
did we see um
obviously within the riots they weren't
uh shutting them down they weren't
prosecuting they weren't arresting
sometimes they were but for the most
part the justice system was not going
after these people they were getting a
free pass they got they got a free pass
in january 17th 2020 january 6th these
people get rotten solitary but when we
saw the police shut down small
businesses when we saw the police defend
black lives matter murals that were
painted illegally with seizure of
taxpayer money at that point i'm just
like you know maybe they're right maybe
maybe they've shoved it in our face that
the police will will
aid in a bet the theft of taxpayer funds
for political messaging the police will
shut down private business and violation
the constitution
why would these cops just follow these
orders even though they're not only
unconstitutional but many ways illegal
outright and and why would i even bother
supporting them at this point well a lot
of them and i think we were talking
about this earlier actually we were
talking about the fact that a lot of the
really good ones they did leave they
ended up going somewhere else and but
but you're only seeing this issue in
democrat controlled cities where you
already have a corrupt mayor because
remember it's not the law enforcement
that's usually the ones who are the
issue they are law enforcement they are
not legislators who are actually
creating these laws or creating these
types of regulations and things that
they're trying to enforce but the
problem is that then the people who
oppose it
they just leave the cities and they go
to another place and they go hey look i
know that this mayor is trying to impose
something which is you know against
something i'm willing to adhere to and
those cities just crumble from that
point yeah but you know when i see your
point don't get me wrong yeah let me
i'll tell you the story i tell everybody
it was when i was buying my first gun
uh i live i was in new jersey at the
time it's very difficult to get a gun it
took several months took like six months
actually because they were lying to me
about how to do it should've went to the
gun shop in the first place but there
was a woman should have been a florida
resident should have been a florida
resident in the first place uh well west
virginia we got constitutional carry so
this woman from pennsylvania uh where
you're allowed to have guns was going to
atlantic city she wanted to go gamble
she was like an older middle-aged woman
maybe in her 50s and
she crossed the bridge she gets pulled
over for like a taillight or something
and then when the cop walks up her
thinking i'll be responsible like i was
told politely informs the officer that
she she does have her her concealed
carry with her just so that he knows and
he said okay you know step out of the
vehicle ma'am uh put your hands behind
your back and she's shocked what's
happening you're under arrest felony
possession you're not allowed to carry a
gun in new jersey
why did that officer do that why didn't
that officer just say ma'am
it's five minutes back to philadelphia
you're gonna turn around i'm gonna
escort you to the bridge do not bring a
gun into new jersey it's a crime instead
he was like i think this woman should go
to prison for four years yeah that
sounds about right to me this is a
regular cop he's not dealing with a
right he's not stressed out he just
decided upon himself yeah maybe this is
an egregious
unconstitutional law
but
far be it for me i'd rather this woman
go to prison for four years than
totally with you i mean let's let's just
play devil's advocate for a minute
though let's let's say that this young
officer who probably hadn't been on the
academy very long let's just go ahead
and throw that out he's looking at it
going all right so i've got body cam
my supervisor is going to look at this
and i have an option to either enforce
the law because he was in the right of
enforcing the law or if i don't and i do
the right thing which is probably to say
hey you know what let's turn you back
i'm going to lose my job which means i
can't feed my family which means my kids
look they're i mean we have to look at
all the things i mean these law
enforcement officers first off a lot of
them are on 35 000 a year forty thousand
dollars a year to risk their lives i
mean i i understand your point but so
does that say that but does it change if
that's instead of it being a 60 or 7
year old does it change if it's a 20
year old does it change if it's a 19
year old does it change as far as i mean
that's my point there's no justification
for someone this is why constitutional
carry needs to be across all 50 states
this is a constitutional right to bear
agreement i agree this shouldn't even be
in discussion the issue here is a
cultural problem
that you would have someone fresh out of
the academy be like i would rather this
woman go to prison for four years than
me lose my job
i mean that to me is evil but we don't
live in a society of
us or them i mean that's exactly what
the good for thee not for me you know
socialist leftist mentality is isn't it
the two-tiered justice system they can
get away with it but we can't well i
mean in chicago a great example is
politicians can carry guns and have
armed security but you can't new
jersey's the same way in fact in new
jersey
uh so i i talked to the police
and i said you know how do you get
concealed carry the only way that you
can have a gun on your person walking
around in any new jersey neighborhood is
if you have a concealed carry permit but
new jersey is actually a no issue state
it's not a real legal distinction it's
just everybody knows new jersey will not
give you one no matter what you do or
say
unless
you are worth a certain amount of money
or you have a certain amount of fame
well then or you know certain people who
will sign off like the share for like
exactly i think it goes beyond the
sheriff i think in order to get signed
off on it it's like state level or
something ridiculous and they just throw
them in the garbage basically and
there's laws about it because it is
unconstitutional but they'll no matter
what you do they'll just tell you to
shove off unless you can prove you you
work with a certain amount of money or
you're famous then they're like oh well
rich and or famous sir you are entitled
to a gun well because they're they're
trying to make the excuse that well i'm
at more risk and i have you know the
ability for people to try and attack me
because of my value because of my but
again though this is that two-tiered
justice system that i was just
mentioning i mean look good for the not
for me i mean
this shouldn't even be a topic of
discussion tim you you and i were saying
that before just go back to
constitutional carry and let's just get
over it i've had uh
situations in chicago stories from my
friends and things that i've experienced
one one story my friends told me is that
they were hanging out at the park and
they were smoking pot when they were
like teenagers
and uh a cop car pulls up and it wasn't
like a patrol car but it was very
obviously a police vehicle
and uh my friends freak out and they're
like 16 and they throw their joint or
whatever and the cop laughs and he goes
dude we don't care that you're smoking
pot in the park we're looking for this
guy did you see him and they're like no
and he's like all right man later there
was other instances where the cops would
come by and see people with pipes and
stuff and then he would be like toss it
bro come on and the dude would like toss
it to the side like you're good so why
is it that those cops in this instance
in chicago would be like i'm not going
to arrest some teenagers for what's
clearly illegal but another circumstance
like
a constitutional right
heavens you got to go to prison for that
there are a lot of stories in chicago of
like a dad
who tried to get a gun to practice
family because the gun violence is so
insane
lock them up go to prison well too bad
you try to get them they deny you even
though it's constitutional right you got
no criminal record whatever so they say
i'll drive to indiana 45 minutes pick
one up and then you go to prison for it
or or the states where they're like you
can have a gun in your car so long as
the ammo is not with it yeah
i mean i i don't know new jersey yeah i
i don't understand maryland is
apparently maryland is that yeah
maryland i'll tell you what so so when i
when i first came to
the dc area and coming from florida this
was a massive shock for me
and it was the same thing i was talking
to someone about oh yeah you know i'm
going to take my you know pistol and
some ammo i'm gonna go do some you know
shooting things like that at this
maryland gun range and they're like what
do you mean you're gonna take your ammo
i was like well yeah i'm gonna save
money because you know i used to reload
i used to do my own stuff so you know i
don't want to pay ten dollars a box back
then or fifteen dollars a box and
they're like no no each round that you
bring is a felony charge each round and
i was like what
i mean this is just insane it's okay for
me to carry my gun but it wasn't okay so
i'm like so basically you're propping up
this gun shop because now i'm forced to
buy their ammo they can charge whatever
they want for it and i'm like you also
in order to buy uh weapons in maryland
it's particularly complicated it's bad
and the funny thing is west virginia is
just
20 30 minutes depending on where you are
in virginia in west virginia if you're a
resident you walk in you got to fill out
your next background check form yep then
they send it to the feds it takes a few
minutes and then you can buy yourself
florida got to do a background check but
uh dc is shocking to me because it's
federal jurisdiction and it's the most
it's one of the most strict
jurisdictions in the country i mean
whether you like the guy or not or
enrique tario he had uh uh 30 round
magazines standard capacity magazines
and they arrested him for it unloaded
unloaded just just pieces of plastic
with springs doesn't matter well and
again i love how people use it
throughout this term it's gun
paraphernalia
i mean sticker of a gun on your shirt
exactly i mean how far do you go with
that
i think i think the issue is you know
i've said this before
if you don't like the fact that people
can have guns amend the constitution
but don't start violating the
constitution every single day because
you're unhappy with it it's it's crazy
to me the constitution is explicit i
don't care about what the reason is a
well-regulated militia being necessary
sure fine whatever the right of the
people to keep and bear arms shall not
be infringed the reasoning is is
irrelevant yet what do we have agreed
they've banned everything i love it when
they're like no one's coming to take
your guns and i'm just like waco
excuse me that was 30 years ago come on
o'rourke's exact comment right which
he's now
gone back on yeah but his exact comment
was is i am coming for your ar-15s what
an idiot i mean look and again if that's
not infringement
of my second amendment rights what is it
i i honestly think that if you uh as in
a campaign declare your intent to
violate the constitution you should be
ineligible 100 that makes sense 100
agreed so when beto says i am going to
take your guns away it's like oh well
that's a direct statement and violation
of the constitution you can't be allowed
to hold power
would you let him run like the next
cycle then like if they if they atone
for the statement
you know it's it is an interesting point
because i'm bitter bit facetious but
yeah how do you recover from saying you
intend to violate people's rights
because then was to prevent you from
once you're elected from going back on
that because you've already shown your
true intent but it just wasn't popular
and who knows if you're lying all the
time hey look well that's just being a
politician if you're if you're a felon
you can't own a gun okay well if if you
express publicly public intent on the
campaign trail to violent constitution
someone should be able to file a lawsuit
against you and then it should go to the
courts and the courts would be like if
for nor the reason that he should know
that he violated the council i'll tell
you what's even worse than that though
what about the felons who you're not
allowed to vote
i think felon should be allowed to vote
i mean that's absolutely absurd at the
end of the day if you go and you serve
and you atone for what what you've been
you know essentially prosecuted for
why shouldn't you maintain your
constitutional rights and liberties why
should you not still be able to vote in
our elections why should your voice not
count thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time